que arnaud viala merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
sans provocation sans intention
polémique
je vous demande s'il vous plaît de nous
donner de donner à nos agriculteurs des
explications au moment où ces derniers
sont à la rue dans mon département de
l'aveyron et ailleurs pour vous demander
de ré de réagir à la crise de toutes
leurs productions à leur détresse à leur
colère vous rejoignez vos représentants
à l'assemblée nationale de rejeter en
bloc et sans aucune écoute pour nos
arguments la proposition de loi élaborée
au sénat pour améliorer la compétitivité
de l'agriculture
ce texte porte notamment sur trois
poèmes la rémunération de l'acte de
production et le dialogue à établir avec
la distribution pour l'améliorer puisque
tout va bien aller le dire à nos
exploiteurs dans la rue
la diminution des charges sociales
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture puisque nos
propositions ne valent rien allez donc
leur dire que vous ne changerez rien et
la diminution des contraintes normatives
et réglementaires
puisque vous avez déjà tout simplifié
allez leur dire au bout de bientôt
quatre ans aux responsabilités vous ne
pouvez plus rejeter sur d'autres votre
incapacité à prendre les bonnes
orientations à un an et demi de votre
bilan
vous ne pouvez plus continuer à faire
des promesses et des incantations tout
en rejetant systématiquement toutes nos
propositions
les agriculteurs de france veulent des
actes
ils veulent que vous considériez
l'agriculture comme une économie comme
une activité économique à part entière
ils veulent des perspectives d'avenir et
pas de plan daide à la fin de vie ils
veulent que vous gouvernez en fait quand
les entendre et vous monsieur le premier
ministre
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
c'est le président monsieur le député ce
que des biens à votre département
monsieur député département de l'aveyron
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
questions
vous dites que ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui résoudrait les problèmes on
regardera ensemble et au sénat ya une
discussion et sur un certain nombre de
sujets il ya eu désaccord
j'ai dit d accord c'est-à-dire des
points de convergence en particulier sur
l'annoncé sibilité des contrats laitiers
sur la question évoquée tout à fait sur
la question des baisses des charges
sauf que je vous le rappelle dans le
droit européen aujourd'hui toute baisse
de charges ciblés uniquement sur une
production ou un secteur ne peut pas
être validée à l'échelle européenne
je vous le dis aussi vous gage et ses
baisses de charges sur des augmentations
de csg ou de tva
faudra-t-il à ce moment là est d'accord
avec vous même sur le fait que vous ne
souhaitez plus d'augmentation d'impôts
pour les français moi depuis le départ
je cherche à trouver des solutions à une
crise je vous le dis vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition une crise
de marché qui dépasse largement la
question de la france puisque tous les
pays européens sont touchés chaque pays
a aujourd'hui à faire face à une crise
dans le port en crise des tiers et sur
cette crise
l'état apporte le soutien qu'il doit
apporter aux éleveurs l'état doit être
là pour moderniser et simplifier c'est
ce qu'on ne nous avons fait je vous
rappellerai que sur les installations
classées
ce qui a été fait comme progrès qui
avaient été demandées passe d'ailleurs
par monsieur le fur qui avait été
refusée par votre ancienne majorité
nous avons été capables nous de
simplifier les altérations classé dans
le port dans la viande bovine et dans la
volaille
donc s'il vous plaît un peu
d'objectivité et parce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition et que la
responsabilité ne vous un compte pas ne
laissez pas non plus croire ce que vous
n'avez jamais fait est ce que vous ne
ferez jamais merci
la parole